what's the first thing you want to do
when you grab a banana call my nana
let's serve up some news sunny side up
we're going to start with style today
ross because the guardian is reporting
that the fashion world is expecting a
huge
boom they've already seen an uptick in
clothing and jewelry sales and they're
comparing it to
the roaring 20s fashion after the 1918
flew in world war one the fashion world
exploded
switched from suits to sports coats and
women got
bobs and put on beaded dresses and
fashion experts
expect to see the same joy and freedom
expressed in
upcoming trends what do you think well i
think people are a couple things one i
would love to have somewhere to go where
i had to dress up it's been a minute
right it'd be nice to feel good get all
pretty and go the other thing though is
i've gotten sort of used to wearing
elastic head to toe
24 7. right yeah and so i think that
whatever happens in the fashion world
that athleisure-ness
which is that like casual when you wear
stretchy clothes but you're not going to
the gym that's called athleisure yeah i
think it's all going to be infused with
that like i just got these jeans and
they're so stretchy i feel like i could
put on 20 pounds and still fit in them
vogue reports facial cupping is the
latest skin care trend
that also relieves facial tension gosh i
need some of that
um literally this morning i woke up and
i was like grind harder woman
oh
yeah i know i've got like tmj so i'm
interested in this i think i have a lot
of facial attention
oh oh oh oh wow oh okay first of all
yeah
man do i need like a product or
like um an oil do i need anything with
it
yeah so the first thing definitely most
important
is to get an oil or serum i'm gonna have
a little bit of oil here
okay and apply it to your face because
you really want to
promote the movement of the cups you
never
want the cups to be stationary on your
face that's how you end up with
bruising you want them to always be
gliding on your face now you tell me
thanks
uh sorry about that i was like
i know cnn business reports that gen
zeerers or
zoomers as we are now calling them have
gone on tick tock to say
skinny jeans side parts and the crying
emoji
are dead no
yeah yeah they do they say this is like
all for old people
they don't get to just get rid of skinny
jeans and
a side part i'm sorry i still i'm still
going to use the cry emoji
sorry gen z what are they they're
zoomers
and my daughter called me a boomer the
other day
and i said i'm actually not a boomer um
i'm a uh gen xer
and um and then i my eyes started
crossing and she lost interest enough
before that conversation went
may i ask what's the first thing you
want to do when you grab a banana
call my nana
okay but a writer of refinery29 went on
a quest to determine the correct way
to peel a banana and the answer might
surprise you
heidi can you read that tell us what it
says it's from the bottom up
no this is that shocked me this is
bananas
that's crazy from down here apparently
we've been doing it all wrong
apparently going backwards going the
other way around
avoids that mealy tip what do you think
heidi
well i also find the bottom to be mealy
and i cut that off too
so i only eat a banana like in them
this much have you ever peeled it from
the bottom i have not
let's do it all right here we go it
feels wrong
oh my god it's so much better and so
much more delicate to not
crank on the handle i didn't like that
i it just felt like against nature ross
i'm totally with you
right i say no yeah no i'm good okay
this banana can split the feet have
demanded crocs they've demanded
uggs and now glamour magazine reports
the trend that is everywhere you're
gonna see it
socks and sandals yeah no drew
i don't know how i feel about this one
really rossie yeah i
i'm just a firm believer that i don't
like that
now is it just because you're like
you've given up on life
or it's just not your trend i just i
went to college and i remember seeing so
many people with socks and those like
adidas yeah showers at the dining hall
and
always being like i almost can't eat i
hate that look so much
i love it rossy we differ i like cause
i'll
rock a sock and a sandal any day but
that's cute for you
maybe maybe you could pull that off i
don't know but i definitely do it
and today it's a customizable cutting
board
and you can do words look at that so
cute
olive and frankie and look at that one
look barrymore
how rad is that this is great and you
know what's so fun is you could get your
family names you could get um
meats cheeses vegan gluten free whatever
for a little presentation i love that
put pithy little things like cut it up
oh make it roll
that's a wrap yes exactly see i should
have left the puns to you
um these are handmade by woodworkers in
baltimore maryland and they use
sustainably sourced american hardwood
and i just love this it's called words
with boards
so cute great housewarming gift too oh
by the way you could put like yeah like
a family name i mean i'm so excited to
have a board that says barrymore
yeah well here there you go oh thank you
yeah spirit and you can put olives on
there oh good oh look